Before jumping into the code let's
quickly review the components
of a Markov decision process,
or MDP, and see how they are implemented
using the BURLAP library.
The first component of an MDP is a set
of states S that the system can be in.
Associated to each state S,
in S, is a set of actions A(s),
that can be taken at the state,
little s.
Additionally, there is
a transition function T(s,a,s'),
that gives the probability
that if we are in state s, and
take action a,
that we end up in state s prime.
Finally, there is a reward function.
R(s,a,s'), which gives
the reward we attain by taking
action a at state s and
ending up in state s prime.
Recall that it is sometimes more natural
to express the reward as a function of
just s and a, or even as a function
of just the initial state, s.
We will use the most general form,
R(s,a,s') in this
tutorial since reward functions are
implemented in BURLAP in this manner.
A terminal state is a state in which
no further agent action is possible.
After entering the terminal state
an agent receives no more reward for
the rest of time.
In lecture, we did not define terminal
states as a component of an MDP,
because they can be considered states
without any associated actions.
However, in BURLAP,
we will have the capability to
specially denote terminal states.
So it is good to keep this concept
in mind as we build our MDP.